hi I'm a journalist we've briefly talked
over email I would like to ask you that
maybe you know that in your field there
are several questions that are
underreported by the media
how could media do a better job while
covering this topic thank you sorry I
miss ed I just wanted to ask you if
whether there are things in your field
that the media doesn't cover or doesn't
come with me no thank you yeah that's
that's a great question so I think and
this is probably just also what what
gets the most attention there's a lot of
stories about the problems right hey I
was doing this wrong an AI is doing that
wrong and this disaster in that disaster
I think one thing that I would like to
see more of is the solutions because
there are increasingly solutions but
until people know that these solutions
exist and both in technology or even
outside of technology they can't they
don't expect the companies to step up
right right now still largely companies
are saying oh yes that's great but we
don't know and I don't think that's a
valid excuse anymore
and unless the public or unless even the
technologies ourselves know that I don't
see how to close that gap
that's on ok so I have a follow-up
question regarding resources that say I
am a data scientist and I either have my
own product or I'm working on a product
and I would like to integrate more
fairness and diversity in it what tools
do I have if I am NOT scientist or yeah
where can I find some tools that can
help me to go in that direction with my
product or in my team yeah that's a good
question so I think largely the people
working in this area are more than happy
to talk because really we're especially
the people who started this early on
we're really doing this because we care
about it right so it's a very open
community in that sense that if you want
to be fair we're like gung-ho about it
right they're not happy to help as much
as possible from from our group we tend
to put everything up online so it's all
open source a lot of people are publicly
available I mean this is part of why I
was in a company before part of why I
moved to academia because I wanted to be
able to do it really freely and I think
that's true of a good portion of the
community so really the the information
is there and most of us are more than
happy to talk I just asked you a
question
I'm sorry the question you wrote
[Music]
so I had a question about well really
two things about the example you're
showing with like the red red blue do
you have like other simple frameworks in
which you can apply the same approach
when it's less binary and you have you
know with the example of like the news
articles or something you're not like
it's not neither you know red nor blue
but some somewhere in between and then
sort of relatedly how do you how do you
deal with like the and are you have you
done research on doing like the feedback
mechanisms of these things as well right
when you showed that initial Delta
between fair and optimal but then as you
showed your first slide like there's
also this sort of feedback mechanism and
and how does that sort of trickle into
these calculations as well as I was two
very distinct question so so let me
start with the first on so I resurrect
me you can definitely handle these kind
of where it's of scale right so I mean
you can decide how to do it you can
either say okay this still counts as
right or they still come to the blue and
then there's kind of a neutral category
or you can have different gradations and
it's just a more a matter of choice
right you kind of want to balance across
all of them do you kind of have a want
to have a scoring system so kind of to
slightly do balance that one red I mean
these are kind of design choices but
once you kind of narrow that down
generally algorithmically there's no
problem I think the more difficult
question here is in learning what that
is all right so for given news article
is it red is it blue how blue is it
because you can't count on the article
self declaring right even if they did
self declare there's incentive to kind
of declare something else right and
largely I I haven't seen a good solution
to this so the
the places that that do this so we've
done this word and was the red-blue he
does this as well basically you look at
the source right so who is publishing
the article and based on your
categorization of the source because you
have a lot of data for the source and
then you can do something right but for
a specific article is very hard to tell
because it's very subtle right it can
also be about the phrasing or yeah so I
think that is really the difficult
question even if you want to have kind
of very fine-grained buckets just
knowing what where to put each article
is difficult so that's I think the main
technical challenge your other question
was about the feedback loop yes so no
I'm not really I mean they were in the
very very early stages of that so we
have yes we have one experiment which
which we're launching in a couple of
months that's basically going to try to
measure a little bit of this search
engine manipulation of fact but so that
one was again very binary so we do how
kind of this more gradation and we want
to measure it over time so how long last
thing is this effect but that I mean
we're just in the planning stages right
now I mean this there's a little bit
that we know but it's just kind of the
one step feedback so we kind of can
patch it together to try to get an idea
of the entire dynamical system but we
don't really have any of those those
long-term studies and I think for that
we we need a stronger partnership with a
company that already has a user base
where we can kind of test some of these
things out so yeah I think that's a
really important step to date okay my
questions around the idea of are we
constraining like all freedom if we like
constrained the results we are
perceiving like what does this make with
our perception and more importantly what
who is like the who should do this
decisions
is it like occasional problem should we
address it like we should do is as
education to do this decision yes a
great set of questions and a lot back
then
it's yeah I think these are this is part
of the interesting aspect of this work
for me kind of really grappling with it
with a lot of these big questions I
think with respect to okay is
constraining constraining or freedom or
what I would say is that by not
constraining and allowing this
polarization that is what is
constraining our freedom and in fact so
I met a couple of times with members
from the from the UN Office of the High
Commissioner for Human Rights and
they're very interested in this topic
from the point of view of freedom of
information because if you allow this
polarization eventually after some time
you just shown one piece of information
I mean there's a whole world that you're
not even seeing so actually it's almost
the reverse by not constraining and not
balancing that is what is restricting
your access to information so this is
really kind of a corrective mechanism
for that now who should be deciding what
that balances I think that is really the
hardest part in some sense I think the
problem right now is that basically
companies are deciding by not placing
constraint is kind of fun
passive decision but it is a decision as
to what what they are they're showing
you so right now it is basically 100% in
control of private companies whose main
incentive is to make money which is not
the same incentives as anything else and
I think as it becomes more and more
evident that these things are affecting
individuals and kind of collectively
affecting society it is something that
has to be thought about in a
and potentially break it regulatory way
again how to regulate these things and
who decides what is and all these are
very very complicated questions I think
one option which would be easier to do
and I don't really see any technical
obstacle other than maybe some UI design
is to put this back in the hands of the
users so I mean we have a lot of I mean
they're just little toy demos but why
should Google decide what the right
ratio I mean again it's an implicit
decision right now whether this is kind
of implicit decision of what the right
ratio of male to female CEOs I see why
can't I have a little slider that says
okay I want it to be perfectly gender
balanced or I wanted to actually match
reality or I want it to be whatever it
is if you only want to see female CEOs
and go for it I mean there should
there's enough ways to collect this
information from users whether kind of
some setting somewhere or something
where I don't see why that option is not
there I mean there's all kinds of
privacy settings why can't there also be
fairness or diversity settings right
maybe I had a rough day and I can't deal
with other side of news so today I want
to see but most days I think I know that
it's good for me to see something
broader and I'm okay with that right so
I think that is that is a direction that
companies could take now that would not
place huge hurdles and if they were
doing this that could potentially save
them somebody yeah sorry yeah that a
perfect opportunity to start a business
which puts the power back into the user
I mean Elon Musk he mentioned I think in
in May when it was kind of upset with
the press he said okay he's going to
launch a website that basically raised
journalists
you know that digression is now based on
what yesterday we saw a representation
on you know identifying the left the
degree of populist of heads of different
states what was quite nice and so my
question to her was welcome it not
extend this to the press because the
media if you look at Fox News in essence
clearly biased and as a user what I
would like to have his kind of a big
window which says this is this is kind
of what we see out there and then you
know when you feel up to it then you you
go to different areas and say okay give
me some use what's what's what what do
people talk about back here over here
right now I don't have that window I
don't want you to see what's out there
and lowest rating so I think I'm not a
strong believer in regulation somehow
because people behave they behave so you
have to put it back into the individual
anyway that so the question is is there
not yeah no I think there absolutely is
I think that yeah as you say boss and
you bring up another point I mean just
the presenting information so finding
the right way to present this
information to users and then allowing
them to control what they're seeing or
when they're seeing what yeah and I
think it would be a great startup or a
smaller company they kind of start doing
this I think a lot of people would be
would be very very interested yeah yeah
yeah yeah absolutely so yeah if you want
to do a start-up on that that's the
problem idea too you have to find
someone to do it but yeah I'm not the
startup type of person without fully
supports it is okay I have a follow-up
question - yes and like don't get me
wrong like I am into like giving
everyone like this possibility to make
settings in the UI and like to decide
for themselves but I see like the
problem or the question of this is like
an educational problem where you should
like if if there is a need to decide
certain things and certain like regulate
certain things for the user and in which
like point it is like desirable to make
these settings and in which it is not
like if you have like something that is
not so spread in education in a way that
like people don't know about it or they
don't realize like they are like
interested in racism stuff or like
they're like if they don't know it so
they should like they need this
education they need access to that when
they don't have it because of their
bubble
so is it like desirable to like enforce
this education like to enforce this
diversity in this case do you think yeah
that's interesting so I think generally
there is a need for more broad education
about kind of what is algorithms or what
is a I mean there's all of this kind of
scary
Oki is taking over jobs and ruining the
world and type of things I think part of
it even before we get to that is just
trying to reach out and have more people
understand I mean what is what is
another and what is it that even any of
these things do and this I think this is
changing with younger generations but
largely I don't believe in there's been
studies that show that most people don't
really understand that what they're
seeing online is not like uniform on by
a sample of what's out there right they
don't realize that things are being
personalised so I think this is really
the first step all right so
yeah I think there was a bit unrelated
study where there was one that was
looking at looking at Facebook and they
basically just brought I mean they
brought people into a lab setting and
they were asking them kind of their what
they don't like about Facebook and then
they told them a little bit about how it
works and one thing that they found
which they weren't expecting is that
after they explained them that okay that
algorithm is deciding okay what you see
was they're like oh they felt so
relieved they said I used to you know
I'd post something and such and such
person wouldn't like it and I'd get so
angry and now I know that algorithm is
showing them something so they probably
didn't even see my post and a plausible
deniability like this huge relief but I
don't know I mean it's just very
interesting how people think about these
technologies which we kind of take for
granted in some sense and I I mean of
course technology is everywhere and I do
think a lot of its coming into the
educational system more and more now
exactly what is being taught and how
it's being taught I mean this yeah but I
do think that the public needs to be
more aware of just what is going on and
once you know what is going on then they
can talk about or then they can be more
aware of settings or yeah I mean that's
kind of I think we're not even there yet
right now yeah you comment just a
question following up on that my wife
always complains bitterly when she has
to watch some Netflix thing because it's
always the same stuff and she never
finds movies my simple answer was well
this thing is optimized for whatever
ninety percent of the population and we
are on the other side somehow and so but
that's it's a problem in the sense it's
exactly that you mean
a lot of the businesses and they cater
to the masses that's where the money is
that's where the profit is in the end
mm-hmm but and then the question is how
do you put the individual back in charge
to say no I want to go out of outside of
this little veil is always showing up
how to get there yeah so yeah I mean I
don't I wish I knew
yeah you know I think a lot of it is I
mean but I guess the thing is I think a
lot of this can be done so it's a matter
of I think once people realize how much
things are personalized then they will
also want the option to break out of it
maybe that's optimistic on my side but
yeah I guess that's what I'm saying it's
like I feel like we're not even there
and that people don't even realize that
they're in some sense constrained and
this way I think it will change I mean
this was true for privacy right I think
people or maybe it's kind of a good and
a bad tailors well I mean a while ago I
would say that most people had no idea
about what was being done with their
data online now they're more aware that
companies are using their data the
question right so it's changing the
actual the convenience right is seems to
outweigh the the behavior in this case
what I'm hoping is that in this case as
in some of these examples that I was
showing I mean people actually benefit
from diversity their own perception of
their benefit is increased when they see
more diversity right so when you look at
these answers or you look at these news
articles I mean no one wants to
doesn't happen as much anymore but I
mean a few years back even on cool you'd
search for something and kind of half
the links were roughly the same thing
right now they've gotten a bit better at
giving you more contact but I mean that
was kind of annoying right that you have
to kind of swirl and people do want
diversity at least in some dimensions
and they do evaluate themselves I mean
this we've seen from from studies so I'm
hoping that this is the difference
between fairness and privacy that the
diversification is actually for most
people something that they perceive as a
good thing just be a bit provocative so
yeah sure there are areas where that is
true so I understand if you take the
American political system where 50
percent is liberal 50 percent is
conservative that you want to show both
views but doesn't that also create false
equivalence so nowadays it's depressing
like usual to see journalists talking
about global warming where they've
invited a PhD in science who's got this
this and this achoo visions been
studying it for 10 years and John who's
a professional John who has dinner and
there's there's this false equivalence
are the same well vaccines are
considered to be protecting the
population by pretty much all of medical
science but here's a professional mom
who thinks that they cause cancer and
you end up creating a false equivalence
between what is essentially commonly
accepted truth by and now to be quite
provocative by the elite who has
informed in that particular field and
giving it some sort of democratic right
to the majority saying yeah but more
than 50% of us think that global warming
is a hoax therefore we should have we
should force everyone to see 50% of that
on Google results that's a problematic
idea as well yeah these are definitely
the sticking points of these problems I
think yeah so there's a few there's a
few different things back in here as
well I think one side of it is just in
terms of
giving access to the information so one
side of this would be that I'm kind of
okay with people who anyway trust the
science to see something every time and
when you're also exposing people who
don't rasayan see some of the facts
right so you have to see what okay so
something might be a little bit negative
what is one is the negative outweigh in
the positive right and I think it's more
dangerous to keep people who are not
informed continually uninformed than it
is to present people who are informed
with some less informed we're at best
you get to 80/20 where 20% so what do
you accept that if you start presenting
that vaccines are a good thing and that
they cause autism at fifty-fifty rate no
so I don't think the right answer is
ever 50/50
I think that I answer something a lot a
lot less I mean I don't know what the
right number is I don't know but I think
really what the right solution here is
is not to kind of present everything
equally even then I won't present so if
you want to be kind of as fair as
possible I think as far as possible as
often not 50/50 it would at best to be
kind of what the population I don't know
that's also very problematic but I think
the right solution is just to have some
okay I don't know 5% right everything
has to be shown at least 5% at least
when I have these binary things right of
5% of your feet has to be some
distribution over kind of all the other
stuff that you don't normally see and
what this does is it at least opens that
window so that you have some access and
then if something catches your eye if
something you click on then you can that
allows the opportunity to kind of pull
back from that corner because right now
there's not even that opportunity so
even if you have a slight preference
somewhere eventually you get driven
somewhere and then you don't even have
the opportunity to pull out of it and
that is really the problem but yeah I
mean I I completely see and agree with
your point I don't think any of these
are yeah I don't think any of these have
[Laughter]
as I said before I'm a journalist maybe
I could tell you how these things look
from the inside there please our first
duty is to the public and what we aim
for is fairness we want to provide our
fair stories for the public we cannot
think in percents something 80%
something 20% something else so it's the
line is quite grey I totally agree with
you but we try to judge each case
individually so
yeah it might not be it it's right but
we try to talk to each other I never
work alone I also I work with an with an
editor all the time and as long as well
what we're doing it's not perfect but as
long as each of us tries to be as fair
as they can so what is so what is fair
mean in this setting so if you're
talking about an issue that presumably
you have your own opinion on does that
mean you as a journalist you would
present that you wouldn't present that
or your presenter but also balance it
with an opposing view I mean what how
does that look I try to leave my
opinions at home let's talk about
vaccines because you've mentioned those
before in the last in Romania we do have
quite a big problem with people deciding
not to vaccinate children so we try to
just leave this information we try not
to give a voice to people who are
against science so we just most of the
time people just ignore that part of the
talk so we only talk to scientists and
doctors and so on because
yeah yeah yeah but uh as long as there
are studies we try to follow science and
as long as there are studies who say
that vaccines are okay just we're going
to trust the science well well not quite
not quite we might know how to do well
interact well you can if you look at
certain illnesses that have decreased
because of vaccines after vaccines no I
think certainly collectively yeah yeah
sure
well the studies that for instance which
there was a huge because of yeah
definitely so yeah network effects are
[Music]
certainly play a role in there there's
the structure which is not something
that we can control but there is the
there is basically the recommendation
type of algorithm right so that's that's
an another area we've been studying
basically how can we make these
recommendations in a more again also a
more kind of diverse or more balanced
way so that basically this information
has the ability to cross write what you
need is for it to kind of jump out of
one circle into another right and then
maybe you can spread in that circle as
well right but the problem right now is
that because of the structure of the
networks where they are kind of
partitioned if you run these typical
recommendation algorithms things stay in
their community right so if that
community is small it'll stay small so
what we want is basically a
recommendation algorithm that again
recommends you things from your
community but sometimes you may be
interested in things outside your
community so also recommends that and
again it's just this not 50/50
but just allowing that possibility right
allowing that piece of information some
exposure elsewhere and then maybe it's
maybe it's interesting and takes off
there right but right now it's kind of
again this implicit decision to box it
up to contain it one of the areas that
we have research is actually in fair
lending we work a lot with us so it's
actually legally binding that you have
to not discriminate in one of the things
we found interesting was that we when
you try and regularize a wave so if you
define a metric like really naively two
groups that are protected need to have
the same false positive rate sure easy
way to start has its own problems but
let's hold that if you start
regularizing away on one pair let's say
let's say on ethnicity then you might
you actually find that sometimes it will
regularize by increasing the the
disparate impact on gender then when you
regular raise it away on gender do a
study into how to decrease a
discrimination against two groups at the
same time so not agree on two levels at
the same time even that they then
interact in very strange ways yeah
definitely so we have a very recent
paper it's online I can send it to you
also so this is on classification which
is basically what you're doing and it
works for any number of partitions so
basically the group structure you can
have arbitrary group structure where you
have any number of partitions so gender
ethnicity et cetera so you define your
fairness constraints across all of them
and then we get you the best
classification that we can that
satisfies those constraints and now
because it's multiple ones it's not
exact so we might have to necessarily
violate some constraint because it might
not be feasible but we basically give
you some kind of approximation
guarantees
you kind of violate all of them by the
least amount possible so that lets you
basically work on all of these things
together it's a pretty general approach
so it can also the other nice thing
about it is that so you mentioned false
positive rate which is a measure but you
might want it to
as you said okay maybe that causes that
disparate impact so you can also control
across various metrics so you want to
say I want good false positive right and
good and disparate impact now again the
more you add on the less likely it is to
be feasible so all of these things we
talked cement but at least it kind of
lets you balance this so you don't kind
of skew one thing and trying to fix
something else yeah if you had if you
had a lot of constraints you basically
yeah often your accuracy starts starts
taking you nosedive after at some point
and again that's that's a feasibility
problem I mean this is kind of no no way
around that unfortunately yeah yeah so
you send me an email or it should be
yeah it's on archive for sure so if you
search for me on archive it's there we
change the team name several times so it
should so fair classification
constraints yeah but it's probably
easier to send me an email and I'll send
you the right link yeah just to add to
notes like you said before in the
presentation like it seems like to be at
some point an impossible optimization
problem and you just may come up with
like the best solution what we are also
doing like in conversation with people
and the second thing is what you
described as like in social studies the
concept of intersectionality and maybe
if you want to like look into it and
haven't it's worth the read I think yeah
I have a related issue question on that
credit scoring thing because I also work
a lot with this and one of the things
that were
turned about as where as we're growing
is the effect that's sort of like you
know as you showed in that simplistic
graph and then and then you have this
knockdown effect where you use are
spreading out the distribution board but
one of the things that I find really
interesting and challenging about credit
scoring problems is you don't get the
data for the people you say no to and
and so we're sort of fortunately working
in an environment in which we have the
ability to to take lots of bad loans
that are denied I'm sorry that are
defaulted but I don't I don't know how
to have like a rigorous framework where
if we want to make sure that we're not
being you know we don't have some sort
of hidden bias where we're essentially
working at some local space that has a
sufficient repayment rate but there's
another pocket and a very high repayment
that we're missing what is sort of like
a systematic way of exploring this space
and making sure we're not trying to like
you know we're only partitioning on the
x-axis in your case but and because that
works really well but the reality of it
is that we add in this other feature or
the y-axis then suddenly find another
region that's well defined of high
payment you know are you aware sort of
systematic ways of thinking about this
sort of the problem of the bias of what
what you're able to learn from your data
when you don't get the negative examples
yeah that's a good question and
unfortunately I haven't seen any any
good solutions to this so the the places
where I've seen some work is basically
when you happen to have access to
different data sets so different
companies will kind of draw this line in
different ways and you can kind of patch
together at least a larger part of the
space sometimes yeah but yeah that's a
that's a really hard question really
there it's a matter of not having data
for for a large portion of the
population so the only kind of solution
that I've seen is some additional
sampling so you add in a few loans that
you normally would not take to do a
little bit more learning
I don't I haven't seen it for a long
time but I think you know the challenge
for us is like what were what I'm
looking for is trying to figure out like
a rigorous way of saying this is this is
a good a good yeah there are there are
kind of approaches for this where you
basically what you're effectively what
you're saying is kind of what would be
the most informative point so there are
there are algorithms I've not worked on
this with our algorithmic methods for
saying okay this is kind of you want to
find someone in this space that would be
kind of the next most informative point
so you'll send me an email and I look
some of it up I'm happy to do that yeah
maybe a little bit more personal
collection you don't have to answer but
I'd be really curious how what is your
vision your personal vision and what do
you fight for so to speak in your
research if there is something like that
and how would the ideal world look like
yeah sure so I think when I started
basically yeah the kind of press or even
the academic articles were largely
negative and that was the first thing
that I wanted to change it was all like
here here are the various problems that
we have right and what I really wanted
was solutions and I've been pretty happy
with how our work has gone over the past
several years that now I really feel
that I can confidently say yes not
solutions there are things that you can
do so that was really kind of my first
mission and I feel like we're on a good
track there I think my next mission
which I've been focusing on more in the
last year or so and which is kind of
very broad how long it ago is now kind
of getting this out right so getting
this in companies getting startups to
start doing it getting the public more
aware talking to yeah and I don't know
if regulation is the right way to go but
at least talking to all these agencies
who will be interested in going that way
so this is kind of far less defined and
it's still very early on but yeah and
that's something that I definitely want
to I want to continue on with had a
couple successes I mean really excited
about this new vote happening in
Switzerland that's that's using this I
think there's more and more interest and
it's great being here I was at the
strata data conference a few weeks ago
also and there's definitely more and
more interest I think from people
actually doing this work in the real
world which is really exciting for me
unfortunately we need to get the room
ready for the next session but I think
Lisa is gonna hang out around for a bit
longer so you can grab her for a for a
chat she will still be around so please
let's say thank you again
[Applause]